but before we go on to our next category
we actually have a personal world as
well because a big part of this year we
felt like was the tour right that was a
massive part of the year that was a big
reason why we didn't get a lot of after
dark this year because we were doing
after dark IRL yeah but unfortunately a
lot of you guys probably did not get to
experience at all you know we have a big
International audience so we wanted to
recount some of our personal favorite
moments that happened on stage in that
moment that not a lot of people might
not know about unless you were at that
specific show yeah so we all have a
personal award that we're going to give
to One Moment in one of the shows yeah
draw me to start yeah go ahead okay so
the moment that stands out to me I want
to give an award to the Chicago show
okay uh because you know Chicago show
was incredible anyway but there was one
moment that I still think back to I like
I as I'm about to go to sleep I think
back to this moment and I just smile
okay um because part of the show was we
had to defend some of our [__] takes
and uh sometimes we had to defend each
other's take even if we didn't agree
with it and I was up against Joey and
Joey had to uh Joey had to argue that
steak was good
and I had to argue that steak was bad
for an American audience oh yes
and what happened is I go first I go up
on stage and I present my argument Dead
Silence okay no I I knew I knew I I
there was no chance I was I was coming
in with the girl I had to argue that
steak was [__] to an American audience
presenting my argument I walk off
dejected off stage and I'm like Joey
present your [__] argument Joey had
the biggest guaranteed dub of all time
all he needed to do was to like stick up
for steak and uh we had about 30 seconds
to make an argument Joey walks up he
gets he gets Applause he hasn't even
like started talking they're like I
guess Applause everyone's like
and he goes my fellow Americans
Joey Joey and if he starts talking about
steak and then about 15 seconds in he
starts ranting on about
all all types of stay so good beef steak
pork chop pork steak chicken steak and
I've never seen an audience turn so fast
with just a single line because he went
from like complete cheers to to do once
being like what what the [__] what the
[__] did he say and he's like my fellow
Americans chicken steak am I right pork
steak am I right and then they all were
just
I still see that in my nightmares like
that is like actually the worst thing
I've ever gone to and then they voted
throws and trashed his history that have
been on camera that one unfortunately
wasn't on camera but I think in my eyes
that was the biggest throw anyone has
done in the history of trash days it was
it was an absolute you say one thing and
the mood just did after full 180. have
you seen that Meme of like the the DJ
guy like and he's like DJing for a crowd
and he's like you know doing
instrumental break and the crowd's
getting into it and then he goes to the
mic and he goes try to relax your anus
every time I see that Meme I'm like I
get War flashbacks at that moment where
I said chicken steak and everyone just
went what the [__]
trying to relax your anus
look bro you probably would get a louder
chair if you said yeah probably rather
than what you said [__] me the Chicago
show gets my award for that yeah Chicago
show doesn't get my award for me shocker
because of that uh mine is more like a
just a general I think uh like overall
tour Award of uh just us you know
because uh one of the uh I guess
punishments that we had to do because we
had like a punishment system at the end
of each thing and one that every time we
pulled it uh that the crowd [__] went
Bonkers for was that one of us had to
sing the American national anthem and I
thinking back on her now when we first
got it I don't remember which one of us
got it first but like you got it first I
think so but like obviously because none
of us are Americans we don't know the
[__] words right so we always had to
like get a phone or get someone's phone
or whatever to look at the lyrics but
the glow up happened where by the end of
the tour like some of us were just able
to sing it off my eye I remember I tried
to go as long as I could without singing
I think 15 shows yeah yeah and I was
like yes I haven't sung it but then I
finally lost and I got it and I was like
yeah I think I had to sing it like every
like three or four shows by the end of
the tour I I remembered all the lyrics
god I I've never been so uh jealous of
the American patriotism so like it was
the one that sticks out to me the most
was the first one we had to do it which
was the Minnesota show I believe yeah uh
and then this was like our second or
third show so we didn't really know what
to expect uh we didn't know what kind of
reaction to expect and I remember one of
us was seeing it and uh I remember like
looking down and looking up and everyone
had stood up bro people people don't in
America they do not [__] around yeah
everyone was doing this or this yeah
yeah something yeah people don't really
care that much no yeah that's where you
go really but like I was shocked in like
a casual audience of anime fans yeah but
they all were like all right it's
America time boys yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I it was just like one of the few
times when I'm like God [__] damn I'm
like oh this is what you guys rave on
about yeah yeah I get it I feel
patriotic now I ain't even American man
God I will I will say such a [__]
Banger of Nashville it is I will give it
to them God [__] down it's so fun to
see yeah yeah what's the Australian
national anthem the Australian national
anthem is like American but not as high
Australia
it's like Australians
it's really fun to sing drunk
we'll give it that but uh it's nowhere
near as powerful patriotic as the
Americans I don't think there's a
national anthem that's as powerful as
the American Wonder sing I can't think
of off the top of my head but even just
singing that I do you just feel the
power especially when you get when we
got to hold that big American flag and
just [__] waving that [__] around I'm
just like yeah like so that I'd say that
was the best moment on the tour for me
all right Connor I think one standout
moment was um it was doing one of the
argument segments and uh it was at the
Tennessee show and I had had to defend
my take of music is just music is just
peeps yeah I was just gone and gone had
like crushed it it was like the argument
was amazing I think you sang and they
like loved it it went really well and
then it was my turn and I was just
getting booed like it was like one
minute of booing and then right at the
end of it I was like [__] this I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna I'm just gonna piss
them off I was like so I'm ranting and
I'm getting all booze and I go by the
way Tennessee country music [__]
sucks and they go yeah oh my gosh and
they just flipped like the whole crowd
went from booing me to cheering because
I thought I thought they loved country
music so I was trying to like insult
them yeah but they loved it they were
like yeah [__] country yeah yeah to give
a little bit of background so Tennessee
is the I believe like the capital or
country music the country at least like
live music uh not Australia in America
yeah uh and Connor didn't just get an
Applause he
yeah you know one of the few standing
ovations out of like every show that
we've had that we had until we had a few
but it wasn't like every show it's like
passionately screamed country music
sucks
just because like you're like getting
booed and you're like you know what I'm
gonna say it country music [__] sucks
he said
oh yeah of course they're like anime
fans in Tennessee yeah exactly what I
mean like yeah it makes sense but at the
time I was like I think we were all like
what the [__] is happening well I
remember we all looked at each other
like what yeah I was like what is
happening I felt like homelander at the
end of like the last three like kills
all right well you know I'm like Oh my
they're clapping for me this is powerful
honestly there were so many good moments
in the tours yeah it's hard to just pick
one yeah but that's not all because uh
we made some amazing memories in America
this year uh and it was such amazing
memories that we wanted to do it again
so we thought this would be a good time
to announce that we are going back on
tour this year yay this time this time
Europeans we are coming to say hi
welcome say hi guys trash taste Europe
tour 2023 is official guys yes so right
now we don't have the specific dates for
it but we do have the cities that we'll
be going to so we can get you or we can
let you guys know on that right now
cities are as follows I think Dublin
London Cardiff Oslo Copenhagen uh
stalcone Stockholm Berlin yes and
Amsterdam yes yes I think those are all
of them they'll be on the screen as well
so don't worry are we on the screen the
venues are currently being booked right
now that's why we don't have the exact
date but it is going to be starting from
August 30th to around September 13th
that's kind of the date right later I
think one thing we learned from the last
tour is it cannot be as long yeah I
think it's almost too long it was a lot
of fun but it was a little like a week
or a week and a half too too much yeah
um so we're doing a lot shorter and
obviously we're mainly doing like North
North West Europe yeah it's not really a
European tour but you know we're going
to Europe and uh well hopefully we'll
see some of you guys then yeah but we'll
give you guys more details in the coming
weeks uh right now tickets aren't on
sale obviously because we're still
trying to finalize everything but you
guys uh we're letting you guys know
right now so you guys can get prepared
for it for when they do go live so yeah
my Welsh boys I'll see you yeah
Europeans we'll see you there I'm very
excited to do a show in London and fun
of all of my friends and family I um
Germans please please go easy on me
please please
you go to Germany's I'm taking you to a
Goddamn Bakery it's gonna blow your mind